everyone may not know daniel kraus
personally, but his brand has founded his
company, namely flix bus,
meanwhile not only everyone in
germany but also quite a lot of
millions of people in the usa when
he bought a legend there the company
greyhound basis i.e. all the
most successful founders of the last
years from germany by flix you have to get
your Kraus on, let's
go welcome back to the
podcast all Kraus what you read is a must,
thank you very much, I then also
tell many a bit that
I thought at least the
obvious topic is difficult for you
times straight or chronic
overload still well well so cool
is different i think it will you can
tell me that demi and transport
dash mobility they will no
longer be best friends
i think we have shown that
the flexibility of the business
will make us quite good  through people
can always beautiful our offer
adapted to the demand and
over the summer we were a little over 70
percent of the people at a high level which is
okay but not now so that i
burst out in joy is simply, as i
said, due to the fact that enjoys mobility
is a good lesson together but
we are here  confident and you notice
wherever the vaccination quotas are now going up
, where the hysteria, the hysteria is decreasing a
bit, that people also have
some catching up to do and that the
topic of
smart, ecological transport
stands for something that belongs to the
future there I am  I'm 100
percent sure you still
have to pinch your ass cheeks a bit
until we have this omicron under control, well
, but I mean you also say
how well developed some operational
professions have been, we can talk about them
, bought some interesting ones,
but above all you have them too
a value actually increased he has
somehow of a few months can do it so
slowly  made a
round of financing so now she hasn't talked to me about unicorn
for a long time you're
on the way to feeling through von dicker
now comes under the title at the end of the
tunnel but
get over half a
billion fresh money into it  is
already somehow a dimension he
knows how three years ago we spoke
it wasn't quite as foreseeable necessarily
before three I and I think it
will be longer we have to look but you
mustn't forget as you already said
the money is for them  thinking about the future
and the future for us is
not only in the flex must but
also especially in the flex tears and
we are also investing in the markets
in which we are now all over the place
and we were not yet the
market leader in the usa it will be now
we haven't
talked about a turkey yet and we
haven't been to
almost 40 countries yet and of
course that's just one  different house number
we are now by
far the largest fan bus provider or
the long-distance bus platform in the whole
world and we are preparing to become the
largest private train provider in
europe in the next few years and
we want to do that again quickly
customer-friendly digital ecological
do it and then you need two three
times 50 in investment and the
reason why the rating
increases accordingly because we i believe you presented a very
credible and for us
ambitious plan for the future and now to work on it in the next few years
so absolutely route you just the topic
china  china for many years it was absolutely
impossible to arrive against the deutsche bahn or
against the national champions you there
were quasi monopolies anyway
how is the break even and
does he get in what something has
changed that suddenly someone
can compete opposite so getting in
was previously  I
haven't been a problem for a long time a
If the bus market exists at all, that’s the only way it
could already
offer private trains beforehand. The training
is that a train is
super cool  a lot of demand, a lot of
traffic, but the
challenge so far has been that the private
providers have not
been able to feel comfortable with the trains and we have
since managed on the subject of green
transportation in addition to the state railways in
europe or let me say the western
hemisphere  the only relevant brent
to build in the set of people are
these superior i get from a to b
and i want to get from a to b i don't want to
fly i don't want to drive a car
both of which are very bad for the environment
then felix bus is always a part  the
consideration and that's why we are
able to fill trains and if you
can do that then you can step on the gas and
that's why you can  let's say that's better than it
was before on the market, but
that's not a login of the partner, so if
we look at each other now and I'm
really hoping for the new government, like the
state
railways, of course, the German railways will be pampered in our country,
cross-subsidies are the topic
we have now played up and down train path prices
and a lot of other things that still
have to be done we need cheap
trust proof that the competition
remains strong and that it is not only temporarily lowered in the
counter kroner context
and
that is the discussion what might be
noticed if you  db group
smashes it is more important that is
transparent there is no money and no
profit transfer agreements but
that what the infrastructure division
does is to provide everyone in the market with a good
infrastructure that is terribly the same
that has to be self-
contained and
long-distance transport must not be cross-subsidised
as it already is  we're still working
properly  ind now just as strong
that we can also accept the challenge in
this direction and
that used to be the small private ones
then unfortunately not again but now look at
yes, so green trains there will be a
lot in the next few years
that we know from the concept  I
think you were also a poster
child from the generation asset light
so you didn't own the samples
heard the platform and the brand
complained about the whole folder made with the
trains I don't think it's like that or
the trains belong to you  part already
similar so they don't belong to
us like you do now in the country whose bus
you buy if you want to buy your bus
but it's the way we
integrated so we're a so-
called public transport company and it's already so
that wiegard is also trying it out that we
for example,
really
provide everything you need that in the
end our partner companies basically
only pay leasing for the
r  provide rolling material and train attendants
, but everything else
we take care of, simply
because the rail system is a
bit more integrated and demanding
and there are not as many
providers as there are bus companies in
germany only when we
started i know the current ones  figures from the
industry there were almost 5000
bus companies and there are
obviously no 5000 train companies in
germany so
you had to do more yourself but in the end you then despite
this situation is a bit as
best of both worlds as you
then have the
the the staff
and the trains themselves are not in the balance sheet
and that's what matters your
partners, it's attractive for the partners,
so if I now but I think I
can earn a lot of money, I can
contact you and I'll open up a
joint train company for you and let
me  Being on the train and signposted is
attractive, of course, it also
takes a lot of effort  ig we expect a lot just
because it is so that we
stand for consistent quality that has
you can't now that's nothing
against you we've known each other for a
long time but if you're like that here I
'll do it and I still have it  a
sister-in-law and
that won't be enough yes we take
a very precise look at each other that we
're bringing an upcoming quality onto the road
or 7 onto the rails in that
case and then it's also attractive
how many many partners
germany currently has on an order of magnitude
in germany we currently have 3
i wasn't sure after am not always
up to date with
the flextreme rifle but 3 and then
in sweden i think we have
another and now let's see the big
problem is not the partner
history  and that's why it's
mainly less than now in the train in the
bus area because there aren't enough trains
so we never could have
imagined that in the bu  llen the bus world that
is the supply is a problem because in
brussels there is just but you ca
n't just go to any manufacturer
can say i would like to have sent it yes
no problem makes the green be
super next week on the tracks it
doesn't work that way  and that's why we've
basically had train material over the last few years
, he's now important
that he's about 200 km
is able to drive a little
faster that we bought together in
Europe and called caught and now the
current new ones  green flex
trends made from the fact that there is practically
nothing left, so we are in
the situation right now that we simply have a
supply problem and can no longer put
any number of new trains
on the route the day after tomorrow
, so we have an advantage for
you  Of course you have compared to the
Deutsche Bahn and co. that's the
only route you're
interested in that's worth it and that  it only
makes times right so i
don't fetch my father to hamburg for example
i also look at the ford flex
train once a lot but there is the
route somehow hamburg ruhr area it
's just kind of only there twice
a day god be there there at all
because  because that's a really good
axis but that's of course
advantages so as far as the time is concerned it
's not just because we choose
which routes make sense and you
have to apply for the
routes and it's not just us driving there, but of course there's something missing
obviously
Deutsche Bahn is also allowed to go to other private
providers in regional transport Frank
has all sorts of things and you have to
discuss that and then click
slots assigned you move of course for
which you think makes the most sense but it
is not said that I will always
be assigned all of them  where you are right
is that we are of course
oriented towards demand that is what we
g  Emacht has also paid off with the buses of
the successor look where is the
most demand and since our offer
is building and that's exactly how the buses
drive, we also drive the trains and
theoretically the
long-distance transport division of the railways can also
do it that way that there are probably strong ones
it may be political
sensibilities, but the tendering business is what we also call public services, so to speak,
that i can drive from my village where
i live to nuremberg, that
's sort of where we as a people have to
decide, do we want that and i'm
for yes and  then it has to be
cross-subsidized it means from
the business point of view it's not what
we do, we can't and that
has to be supported, as I said,
because when I see how many people
in my village can go there, it ca
n't be a business  means it's
just a question of whether he wants it as a
science analogous to
switzerland in long-distance traffic it's like that you
of course we just had to see where
the demand is and then the offer has
to build there and that's the only
way how it works and that's how
we do it exactly and in the primeval times
as I said it not only has something
to do with it but also that we  we
all share the infrastructure in the
rhine area i mean when it
comes to the buses i can't imagine
how you as an entrepreneur would go there and
say okay i'm talking to the
bus companies call the line up it's
kind of a
phone book or two but
now we've all found and then  talks
about him and then you use
a platform to convey the
orders to the team for the trains we can only start
then so you get on there there
were these private railways and they’ve
been telling you about it for a long time and
there was a real old man
hamburg-cologne-express you can
maybe still as an old hamburger and
there was one that
the hessians left the locomore exactly
locomore from stuttgart to berlin
and they did some cool stuff
but they had the problem that
they couldn't offer it in a nationwide network
, they had virtually
no supplier connections and
they just didn't have the platform like us
with millions of visitors who are always
looking  where can i start
and with that they are it just
didn't work and then they
approached us and then they concluded a
partnership and
then we tilted the whole rhine, so to speak,
and painted it green and it was
just that that you are that  our
partners ultimately think partly
before that, among other things, the flag
on the way and it itself playbook
almost somehow the usa I mean
you think that's the last big headlines
of you guys you
bought yourselves American icons
greyhounds they're talking buses again
so  yes I press the usa but I
used to be greyhou myself  nd fallen
usa that's there are books about
that we don't say wrong i made it
but the sword i thought it was
huge so priced on what you
experience that you meet people or but
it's nothing new there have
been books in it for decades  was that a
bit of an american cultural
institution already these buses and
then this company i have also because of
the pandemic was a bit
under fire or or
economic in trouble and then
you're okay that's the activity
we sort of buy greyhound
I think  it's my
personal opinion they've been running for a
long
time i would say they weren't optimally managed i
'm the same man you can make more out of the
german railway but
politicians aren't the best aigner
and it was the same with ground, they had
before a british one  Group as the owner
and I think he was and he had
nothing to do with regular services, certainly with
traffic but not m  it regular service and
that's just our own business what
we do and that's why i think it
wasn't the best aigner and then of
course it was so that the pandemic was
n't conducive either
because we already talked about mobility
no matter where in the world  nothing
together
and then
an opportunity just arose for us and as
you said we are now the
market leader in one fell swoop this is one of
the household brands at all dogs
over 100 years old everyone everyone
knows that and that is very
complementary  to us, well, in
the last few years we have already made a
lot of gains on this potion of soot only between the big
cities and in
many areas california were already the
market leader in some changes to number
two the compliment he is the grand
nation has a wide network and they
really  connect everything that
is not connected in any other way
, that has no airport,
they have removals  not
really or only very little and
better to build up against such an
established who has been working for us
for years if at all
and now we have the complementary in
the market that can expand
and we can expand the long-distance bus in the usa
i think another one  give a boost and
i'm talking about the renaissance
but we do believe that we
can now
grow the entire market again together with the two brands
that would also be painted green
as you say somehow it will just
be one that we'll keep the brand
for the first time  it's just too valuable and
your old stuff will also turn
gray the point-to-point connections
let's say boston new york or los
angeles vegas it will be more flexible and the
nationwide network will stay longer
we will of course be the
corestate and we'll do it like that  you can
have all inventory as a customer anywhere
but you will both s on the street
before both are okay okay
and you can get what you pay for it there is
a public number
there is no public number but it
wasn't very much but that's
it so the number that i found let's
say it's the talk that
at least  that's not for you in any way,
but we could read it
, it's about 40 million dollars
, you had to look, it's
also deducted, however, you were the
enterprise value, that's really the
purchase price and son, then when
you say it was  not from us then
it was probably from a seller and what
you want so
maybe because we are fewer but it
was we feel very comfortable it was
price performance i had everything perfect
and knew how much had bought now
and for buses i even know  not
that I don't know at all but certainly
doggedly no no so 1000 meanwhile by no means I think it
's four digits
but I don't even know by heart
what  I know that's what I wanted to say
is you're already a little
unsure because the model is different
so you have what I bought what we
bought for example we have we
have now converted our own
buses so we really called
ourselves we caught him  po with bought
in hollywood where all these
props buses so it was so that
despite
an excellent price for us and
the huge potential you with a
first tour than expected
hopefully it's exactly how
we imagine it and you have I mean
it  a huge store and the usa is
now that's one of the most
elementary individual businesses for us if the
usa flex and belongs fit together
and when we even got to
know each other the first week he's such a great
bunch that was really going to be great at the time
I'll be next week  back over there
and they're really up for it because they've already
noticed we stand for a vision of
smart and green mobility for people
about but chosen to be available to everyone
and we have
a better idea than the previous aigner about long-distance traffic
and customer acquisition what they want
and she is super excited
increase in knowledge he has that is fun ok
meanwhile such a
larger acquisition with the trains  and
above all he should probably grow massively in terms of sales as an entrepreneur before the pandemic there was this one
billion as a sales figure you can
update that a bit it would be
difficult because this year and last
year what that is is highly volatile
we will now at the beginning of the year is
the new  publish prices support
that will be a bit better than
last year but not quite where
we want to be yet i can't tell you
100% this year
but we will that's our
our starting point or our base
and what we intend to do is  already from
the points ago what you said that the
height but we know exactly  e it's
that's i have so for a short time is
clever to the listeners that you're really cool
we're not talking precisely about sales
that philipp knows and philipp is
the only person who managed
to elicit that from me the last time or because of that
right on your face
welcome home so
i can't say exactly i can't
say okay but summer
passenger numbers that was at least
communicated that before the pandemic you were
also a smaller company back then
60 million people fell with you
what is gigantic is then is  it
dropped me under obviously
currently we were over 60 million
people again neither we
assume but it is more than last year
last year that pushed down we
assume that you will consolidate a bit
because then also support
said grant come in again that
that  this year will probably be
roughly in that direction again and then
next year the ambitions are w  Everyone
else but that's the problem why
we're so careful with the
numbers
I would probably have more solid
information if we spoke two
weeks ago or had three
now we have to deal with how
we adapt our plans because that's just around the corner for
him  it's
actually a little bit brother
and and since we always
look at what the demand is like and
adapt to it, it's not very precise
to say what exactly means adapting to the
demand when you
realize how I do it, that's how it works  they
then simply say the
connection has been canceled or take out the
times and they have streamlined the
timetable or something else a few days
a few days so we'll see we've
also learned a lot about
adaptability
now we have to yes it was
if there were
new regulations somewhere and we ca
n't do it anymore  drive because of course we stick to
it or there is
a new one somewhere  e variant where we are heroes have
business then you notice that very
very quickly via the online traffic and
then we can adapt the
offer to the demand super quickly according to the cd
because we always want to
have a Hohenroth factor for various reasons but it is logically relevant
and b  because you only earn money like that and the
worst thing is when you
shake and shake all the vehicles and that's why we
now have it that used to be more like
weeks now we're down to
a few days and that we
can adapt to that and as I said it's the
best time now  in the summer it was up to
75 percent but there were also
times when we were only 50 percent of
what we had before Fortuna
and there was right at the beginning if
you remember in the
first block then I think there was a
second one  I'm not exactly sure
, we normally had 400
connections a day, 400,000 connections
and we just said it  i do
n't just want connections anymore so it was
temporary was just a break
and that's natural then so you can
imagine and controlling head of the
cloud has always been applause and the first
time a new budget new loco
templin has enough to do a lot of people
here right now  on the pilgrim so now
about everything how many people work
on the 1300
1300 most exact exclusive exclusive because
i know
what i exactly exploded
the markets are us germany and usa
so the biggest and most relevant markets
for you and then come turkey usa
is now overall if  you reflex us
already take first place you have in
europe it is by country this is
france germany italy turkey
is a big market for us because we
can take over 10 coaching market for in 2009
that is also a great
company and what is now hopefully in
in the next few years it will
move towards the top 3 that will
happen we think two weeks ago  i
started happening
said so casually and that but about an
acquisition or or about the normal
normal market entry what the
acquisition
it went back to set
up here you come here what you a bit that
you don't so personally more erratic
yes a strategy and if you do that
it's a market that has now been regulated
there are already players there are big
local bus companies and
if that doesn't turn out to be the case that
with an acquisition we'll very quickly
come closer to our goal of market leadership in a region if you country
what is now the usa the  was the case or will
be with the acquisition
then we'll just do it
organically at first we learned
that we made the parts made in
france that's fine because
otherwise you don't have such a big advantage, so to speak,
you have to have one like that too
opposition reckon if I'm a
bit like it yes no shopping tour
now no konsu  m 1
but i was the whole construct at the end
what the endgame so you do trains you
do how can europe to south
america makes north america buses possible because
then you also there how likely trains
if it works then one
day when the pandemic will be reprimanded to me  the
stock exchange or something like that,
you obviously had a good time with this whole spa source
, there were no rumors, true, I also
had them,
mr  and
that was also possible before the pandemic,
the whole cash flow together is simply being a
normal company and
not just somehow just
burning cool ones and then there was one
possibility, the bakery was
also just another type of
financing besides the private one and we
deal with it  us so we are
not quite yet but we are working on
that we that we honest s  ind because you
always want to actively shape and not be
shaped but there is
no specific goal now because because as
you said, why should I
ring a stock exchange bell and then do even
more regulatory processes and
finally make it dead if I have
no reason now  A reason who, as
I said, comes when I don't
need
investment sums that are no longer needed or when
our investors push us there, but we
are very happy with the people
we have on board, some of whom have been with us
for so long. Wood,
for example, brings them and therefore them  again
relatively relaxed but you want you
want i will say and that i have
that a bit out of the sewing box as
now this pack source quasi as word
of the year to
say all i don't know all the details
but all all you know them you the
i know we are from the press
i would say you all have that super
nice woman on one side but it's like
you have to go with  talk to them because you have to
understand it so i don't know how
it went i wasn't like that at the
beginning but yes i understood exactly
what the difference is what are the advantages and
disadvantages what is quite normal an
ip or what is a day with  gestures
like spotify did but
had to speak because you're just
getting smarter in the course of the show and
then the question is don't you have gard
if you don't hate then it has
nothing to do with the possibility that
we find bugs stupid  it's not like that
but then i don't just need
compulsive he so who think we
just have is pissed off by people by the
pandemic and now in the growth plan
execute the strategy topic trains now
brazil started i have enough to
do i don't have to now and if  you i
still practice a bit
on a bell ringing by the way
the growth was just so when you say
about kleinmachnow countries up but in the
end she had to au  ch simply lead new
people to the brand on the product
where brought the people from
is that allowed to me in front of google ads that you
simply switch to this connection
or do you notice in the existing one
is that the topic of retention
is becoming more important is not only  christians
because you want us to be the same and because of
the mixture next to germany that you
now have train and rain you have per se
other customer groups that you
can address families
for example you can
pay the flextreme playgrounds and we
can run around the time and stuff like that
is it again we
father of two are hornier than him in the bus
and and then that means you are addressing a
few new target groups you are important to me
on retention
perspective cash registers are running we
young zones didn’t have to check that you got
all your numbers like you  she
mps early not only
raises crap like happy cindy but then also creates
combinations it has an
effect a  on the customer lifetime value
and then of course you also have new
markets as it happens that is
just completely new was not there for
it and then there are the reasons but
brazil is it then really also
with tv advertising and others or
or partly me  so partly
we know our our main server tourist
already performance marketing very
classic that's where we stand the most and it
's best if we have a great team on
board you can count on it that's
transport transparent so done and
marketing spend and stuff like that and then that
's ours  but home hits everywhere where
we got a good deal, we also
when the train lounge
started this summer with all the stress
, we also did a
lot of advertising in germany and why i
'm completely distracted now because i
don't know if it's him  what's going on here
yesterday evening I had some with a
topic of co-founders in the hot and
it will be at some point  n at the beginning of the year
how do you get on with it i
personally know our managing
director of epson and i know that
a couple of 20 people work there now and
if we still fax after the second
ladies i have to say sorry
download that is actually sometimes
a bit  frustrating because my
claim is i'm hornier with people
i'd like
to talk to more people but of course that makes the pandemic more difficult
on the one hand and on the
other hand it's so big now
that i don't know every
point anymore i still have to find myself
and we know that a lot of you
taylor betrayed at that time or e-commerce
companies are now coming up with the idea of also adver
ising in my retail media, so you a
e then why can you place advertising all at once
r that if we have the reach
as you have, you are also, so to speak, adver
ising business  uses once so makes it
really huge and it's successful
now you think you've got
it ever  now there are 60 million passengers
or not maybe only 40 0 you yours
lf indicated it could be to
ards 60 million contacts that
e somehow had these are very
ntensive contacts because the customs are i
the vehicles and so when
ill that happen  media business
we've already done this as a test,
not problems for a good cause,
for example, we ran
a campaign together with the federal ministry of health and
we now have a small team from
hazy the media ourselves,
for us it's elementary that we're there
on the one hand  side of course we'll
find something that makes sense isn't
that
's a great place but i do
n't want it to be like if i'm
personal again from that but his he was
exactly what i have yes logical but
and that's why we're very precise and
talk to some and if that
suits both students as well as
brand value and there  it's
elementary we're a bit piggy and i
think it's right then something like that
will happen well that's not anymore we
've ruled that out for a long time
but it's like sms and others do
what you said but
that's a risk of that huge potential  and the
passengers in the vehicles but also
before that, of course, only what concerns the website
traffic and
we have been dealing with it for
almost a year now, I think, and
if something happens
then you will probably see it here at the time,
but I have it  really
as it is because we are so cheap
and say
no, we want you that doesn't
fit it is always a long
discussion because you often have so
I know I don't often have you
felt it is objectively you have brands that
really  have to play on all channels
and then also have to pay extremely high prices
or do you think rp i already
understood why is it where we are then
say that's not the perfect fitna
so we want to we do
n't want to lift our customers
and i personally don't know how to relax
sleep the most when i'm somehow
on the road with a buzzing moving thing you of course have what
you have more value but several thousand of
great possibilities i  think about
it that makes
my colleague o'leary do it too he's
great that i always come up with awesome things
where you the master
of suspense and statements but i
alone to consider that the individual
trains of you collaborate with a brand
you could paint something on it
you could work with the buses of
course they could
somehow there so you have the
tickets so somehow in the on the
ticket could somehow be something on it
so in the defense if in doubt there are
millions of contacts you have  Yes,
you are right, but this is only a
discussion because you sound like one of
our creati  ven you are a
creative degree when you when
you look at the outdoor advertising elevators
dogs on buses that is operationally super
complex you have to stick them
and stuff like that and it's not like that, like in
air traffic, things eat up too much as
possible  on the track or other
rottweil only then do they earn money that
i can i tell you we
take part of the fleet and then i get
the core brand that is extremely
complex processors and then it has to be calculated like the
dow and that’s how it
is  simply a question of the overall
deal and the willingness to be
willing hasn't been there forever and it's been around for
almost ten years and I would
say it's been around for
almost two years
now and if we find something there now let's do it
everyone will listen bock
has and this coolness let's talk but
so far there hasn't been a perfect match
and there's already something like that there you can
also watch funny funny definitely a
So perfect match means for a
brand that wants to work with
you or does it mean for the
entrepreneur who has been building
up the media business for the
Magdeburg company since this year but that's like
if you're open for the business side
I'm sure people will be there now
hear and say okay i know first
be the subject particularly attractive
so to speak for the first time what to do
we attract much
more attention and then he can only be the one who
lays out prospectuses in flex buses
or who
is allowed to say something belonging to the passengers or
who then sends something to the people who then somehow and
behind him maybe get something
afterwards or something like that in a
data protection well and that of
course only works if the constantia is
better but you can find the solution for
that so it’s clear that I’m considering the
solution is that  That's right, I
don't want it at all somehow because now in the
gray areas but just to say ok  ay he
offers the range and contact points
was the first he can do it
that's gigantic so like
i said we're open to it and nothing has happened so far maybe i think it's a pity maybe it
's still very conscious that such a
make an intro to you or has there ca
n't make any info about me michaela
testern and our own boss continue and he
does that too sometimes i've
done it 12 times so far
as
said she still has i am i'm curious
i would  happy but of course
there was bold somewhere on it it says
fine that's for us of course the same as
jesse area because there
but I so there I would tell you
where I that someone's turn so
now somehow david
let's say otherwise what I also sometimes
noticed from you or
at least you don't do it completely
anonymously he also participates unfortunately
investments now have to have vlexplus founders
but there was somehow r  hit really big
things just like the three of
us we casually said our family office
and that’s of course also
involved in the fixe as
reasons and even as a person there
actually meanwhile it’s quite clearly the
managing director so it’s legally
separated and it’s out of the family
office  is that we have now
made more than 40
investments because we are simply keen on
entrepreneurship because we think
we are already talking about the
fact that he personally believes
entrepreneurship correlates super angel
innovation and super closely with education and
those are all things in the company
education  innovation what germany
absolutely needs and where we
are underdeveloped in my opinion and
now it's still the case with the really fat
red ones so she's very anna is sex
is funny but there's
the european investment found further up and
there's the revolution  size of
european german as it is
and what wasn't
possible to that extent with us before is that
when you see preez you do it
then you get christoph meer or samba from the old
generation of entrepreneurs
and also the one after that
the the zalando boys we like that  it's
just already there you can build
something really cool in germany
and that's why it's cool that it
flows back and
what are your biggest hits right now so
i've seen flies for example
because your podcast also a couple of weeks ago
and
these i have yes  i only give the
calendar
of the
former with podcast
there is still
advised, for example, simple club have now
recently made insurance areas and
naples club is a video tutorial
so logisticians as once earliest
investments real classic is
the creed these are
sausages that are particularly healthy and
low-fat but
for example with with because they don't with
autumn and that means welcome  en
thought pervaded
that we did we did
[music]
we did everything that's how it is
factory automation with robots
we made a lot of effort it's
sort of an operating system for for car dealerships
so it's spreading not only in terms of
quality and we're watching
we tend to have
relatively less mobility if you
think now okay the flicks they had to
do only mobility then it's not
right was what's important to us there
has to be a market that's basically
big enough for the idea it wasn't an
idea spooky as you like  if only
for that we think they will be
great if you stop it quickly
and
then what is elementary for us is the
top system that they understand each other well that they
quickly get the hang of it they
think entrepreneurially because what you do
there is a certain
probability that you have to
rotate a lot here and there, but if the
team rocks through and there is
basically big enough then  not
when i say the idea is secondary
but it was then executed
and so we look at each other we look at
young companies also get the
ones that come our way writes he is anna
big enough is cool our team is there
to step on the gas
and so on  that's why it's motley so
really and like cook as well as you look
at the companies are bigger now where
you actually close first so my grandpa
is now somehow additional
looks they were worth almost 90 billion so
you can invest on the stock exchange they
are of the model  not that far away
from you do you look at all
or is that not an issue for you
you mean now as for as an investment
or as it is in general it is the
assessment that is standard
everyone who is the giant will know through layers of
the digital world  yes yes there are you
always have to be a little bit careful with the big valley companies and especially in the mobility
sector is
impressive w  because it was built,
it's cool, but our
claim is
to do it ecologically and that
's not necessarily the case with the
flooded in cities and even more cars,
firstly, secondly, it's important for us
that we have this
partnership  they also have to do
things themselves, for example,
simply hired our driver and you didn't have a
precarious employment relationship first and last
but not least, I still remember very
well the sentence from dara at the empire
or said he doesn't know how to survive than
makes a profit and  that's now
german companies no longer to say
loessel invests but whether anything ever
comes back which i don't either that's
why the rating is
fascinating and great but that's not
the only thing that counts and
that's why you look at it
because what we all  having together is
the regulatory issue and what
makes it brilliant is
always to look where  can i do as and
business is how can i
diversify stretches dash oberried
and
then other forms of mobility or
modalities in the city and stuff like that and
that's cool so the store is cooler
but it's not like i'm
there with the den  running google ticker
and then I think my
entrepreneurial actions or
investment actions
have to be aligned accordingly that might be a topic
so in general but then such areas
as well as anger or something to go in
so when I think about it an incredible
amount has arisen is not keyword
less  probably a bit far away from
you but the theory is logistics
stuff that is not
really that far away now that you thought about
what was we used to have we
shared
thank you
the main challenge with these
logistics shifts and now it doesn’t matter if
the palace  or so so post and
parcel or whether that's good the long
distance is not the k  ust the last
time is the construction of our
core business which jan pommer require
distance that means i'm again dependent on something
else which is additionally dependent on the last
mile and we have
n't found a deal with the processors and you
have to you can't just do that
and that's allowed  once somewhere but you
had to you have to establish the process
you have to make it very lean you have to be able to
install and we have
dad where to talk that works this
topic doesn't go together with our core business
and then maybe it's nice
but it's just not a
first thing  not part of our brand that's
why we make partnerships when something like that goes,
so look at the
last mile, the partnerships are
whether it's with ubs or with the cinema
or preferably with the entire local public
transport system in leighton, which is always
difficult because
public contracts technology is
super difficult that  you that you already
offer the customers a great experience
is consistent but we will
not do everything ourselves so we have
already learned cobbler stick to your
last and that is long-distance traffic but what can generally be seen now in the mobility area
where I am waiting for you to
come is this super epson so I
had recently  the market berg from
before alex sixt also has it
from 56 so also consciously pulling other things
into your own ranks that is
not for you
coming to work now i can actually only
book your products i can honestly
with you now  in your book and i
can't find a car yet so how do you
get that
we
if we can make money with it the
warsteiner predicted now you
can put it in the you can't because
the complexity if you're
building the app you have to is mine  trainer and you
have to make sure that the
customers address it sufficiently because
the commission business in
most cases isn't  so
easy because you have interfaces right into the day
and then you mustn't
forget that the people who don't
make up our clientele come in
most cases with and s train and
tram and now not somehow
with something like 66 and i'm satisfied the
shareholder
alex  and art treasures the subtleties
not with the six bmw things to
the flix bus but drive them we
said - and the
office preferably gets involved but almost
every shop in every city has a different
system and i can then i have to
negotiate  because I don't want
it to be a capitation fee again,
but of course I only want those
who want to book the gloomy ones on demand,
but that doesn't work again and
that's just real we try to
get it working on your case at least once a year
and  unfortunately so far is not
the case and we are we are
really
merchants we want the best offer
for the customer with the best price
bring it to the market that only works if you
calculate precisely if you if you then
the offer is exactly in line with the demand
and if you don't do chichi
even if it's actually cool
i think it's great and i hope that it will happen
and i hope that maybe too
now in the traffic light because it is not only important in
germany but also
in europe
the platform is created that
the data exchange is simplified because
everything that existed before vdv and so
hübner was complicated i mean
we are talking about daddies who were already
there  i wasn't born like that and
according to the motto well that's easy that
's not up and that's why i think
it will come i hope it will come
but that won't be the case tomorrow
and we still don't have a path for us
that it really will  leads to us making
a profitable or no faster
growth that means not
taking back bicycles or scooters here
or something like that from you  or
david lorenz and i were recently
together at a conference how the
residents talk because it's also just
a cool place so what's the
vacancy rate of it are you exactly the ones
there is always water we used to have
bikes i don't know
which provider there was  also tested a thousand
consolidation rounds again
as I said that’s cool but i
can’t just do it because it’s cool
in tourism bottom line at least be
nice nice and there was animal
like I said is just great for illegal
founders and we do it again and again
what we have with alex is like that and the
taxis are also tested in berlin,
so we are already doing that but the
question is what i said earlier,
war is cleanly integrated, very
lean and scaled and then
it's just not enough if i now  only
in the cities where there are cooperations with which
probably only with a taxi
service in berlin has the cooperation
or only only or in one  m country with
over a cooperation because you
want you want if the
people get used to it in the best case because
you always want to have siemens and you do
n't want us to look in the city and
then they have other service providers
and that's not good either  But that means
this whole super app topic is a
system in general, so I mean that's
just a question
I need to install other mobility services,
but I mean
your situation is also millions of
people have your app or have
to tell you to use it in some way  you
inevitably there you could also
besides that everyone who has a
mini billion company dreams of making more out of an app in the
area on the road despite the poster of it
so
as well as sebastian from smaller times to me
for example for example me so son
is great  app not not in the sense of
mobility that you really that
i dream of that you there where doris
fingerti  pp that you simply have a
favorite band then say here when
you go into the air i really like
lufthansa and i
say explore there the british say
the stuff in ries and if you can then
manage everything with your favorite percentage  that's kinda
cool and of course we hope and you and we hope
to become
our goal for contra station the
treadmill at all, so
a lot has to happen in that direction
, but that will come slowly
basile because i don't want it
to end then somehow google everything
pictured we have to see
that we clearly define our findings in
europe and we are over
the fist anyway i that the country or what
public transport at all then
also works flextreme fix that we are
ahead of a region and we have to improve it i think we have to do it
again  and like me, I'm in
good spirits like the eu
commission, a lot will happen if
you tell me  t complete super apps
and that's the best example
probably more here tencent and
offers and stuff like that
i don't know if that works in europe
just says i'm
unsure and then the question is who
isn't stupid if you have something like that
because
the pandemic has caused you to have
plastic in your hand very often
and that so often looses
probably more often you
put your hand on yourself right now it's
just like that I was somewhere else
and that's why the question is
who's who  the right one and
so that's nothing outside of the
traffic where we're just
leading ourselves to say we're going to do it new how
flex chat flexfix was makes makes it
yes i'll say you as a live band
are consciously doing things about this leif
brandt topic  strengths i mean
simple is good service
that's clear that's the first word to
say it has to work there are customers who are
happy  in addition, things
that you do meanwhile not the famous
hotels earlier me my marketing
lessons learned at the
university who put plastic ducklings in the pools
or put them in the bathtub in the
hotel so that the customer thought
people knew that here in the hotel that is
so  the famous chocolate heart of air
berlin
we try to offer a high degree of
flexibility
when it comes to
rebooking and stuff like that and we also
try the johanniter
you often have the problem with us in competition with the
white guys you
just stand  me on fridays when
i take the very fast train
from berlin to nuremberg then it
's just like but earning that
for us there isn't always a guaranteed
seat and that's just flowing as much as possible
that's what we
do and we have me  don't
forget that what we did at the beginning of our
career as a fixed thing is
we just put it on the internet in d  the buses
brought there was nothing in all the trains
and that's just that,
we're trying
to do sensible things and do a
lot of surveys, market studies and stuff like that, but
now there are so few gimmicks or
red hats  not with us
nowadays it's probably not your
whole
way to do the rubber ducky but you could have no
idea any particularly humorous
announcements sometimes I think to
myself Deutsche Bahn I somehow
drove a little bit during the week
and sometimes it seems like that
self-motivation such as a conductor or such
a train driver who messed up
something funny even reside saying
means the trains are train drivers who so
of their own accord there from the announcement so
a kind of happening make our
partly because something through says we
are the same time as well yes so it
Of course we also have train drivers and
bus drivers who simply have a good
mood
the press respects that is allowed that
is also desired and allowed it is
allowed great but they should be
friendly and polite and i say
then creativity is free
will i mean i was involuntarily
creative when i was undercover
boss i think but
that was it  age has
brought something but can you do something
that's a hassle for the person so
for our team and especially me it
's exhausting but it's cool because
you really say that with the comstage
otherwise never be with me  there must be
said but also his
tv shows asked
if you would want to do it, so to speak
no own people are as undercover
find that again then i was already
upholstered wearing artificial teeth hair
styled beard off that was the worst
i tried others as usual
contact lenses and
then you're wearing so I was on the train
traveling that's cool and
what's the point of that well  of course extreme
attention because that is
repeated again and again and the media library
is and that is like tv advertising only
in tyler and
i say cheap yes insofar
as that is
yes i have here even the back is
broken is so so so but  it
's awesome it was all worth it and that's exactly
where i made nice
announcements and
that's when you do it for the first time
he's at travel iq
so
i know you've got very
tight days it's understandable many
many thanks that i  because again in the
podcast rheins should suffer five
hours each currently thank you very much and for
the update i hug all of us
that i mean are also a
bit of a pandemic
break out when is so how
we actually agreed we
two that i last year  come to
hamburg
for the conference and 17 17 stands stands
next stand everything is planned that
today everything is fully planned we hope and
you probability  I also want it
to be much bigger that it works
yes yes yes everything can be blown out here
before exactly all day please 1
so he who alex has already been
promised would like to have a really great
mobility crew at the start
and I would be super friends
have dinner where you also have fun a
lot of our together i know now
a few together we have both
i will try to guide everything up
and so please put it in the calendar and then
i will tell you that you made it here for such
a pre-christmas update
thank you
so that we have the conversation with
daniel kraus and now straight into the snap
update with thrillers, by the way, we followed each other
closely if noticed we have been
doing quite a lot of
joint formats with snap in the last few days, a
cooperation, among other things, there was also
a longer youtube where me  a product
manager from the stick in berlin explained
what's so new at snap, there's
just all-round ki, too
götz have to say something right away but that's a
warm welcome very normal
philipp thank you very much then loaded if so
how will you get it did you show me
about the past life postleb there being i ended
up in the online industry in 1999 more
by chance
we sold benner at the time  quite
basic then had such a
classic sales time in the
online industry was the last 15
years at google and two years
ago I was hired at snap and that the fun of
my life i used it
much earlier and knew
what  i get involved and what a
cool product it is so you do
n't really have to be the generation
step anymore but my kids
think it's really cool that i work at
umladen and that i'm the
user here
when you hear snap everyone talking  last
attacked is now in the dressing room
we were actually always that i
mean that's our dna and that's how
we started we be  characterize ourselves
as a chamberlain company and of
course it was always in the dna but dna or
respectively has simply
evolved and it's really
exciting what kind of technology it has
become and so in the last
few years it's out of its infancy and
out of the niche  and totally arrived in the
mainstream and today it is
completely lived by the users and
also by brands who understand it
and see how they can build on this
trend and the time is over
when it stood for bunny ears but today it
has become a tool  and
is a real tool gained in our
lives what were clever
marketing makers or brands with snap
currently also the audience
trying it out i think that's
the most important point so it's exciting
that you can map the entire funnel
so that's both for branding
customers  a great tool to make products come alive
and to
give experience but also for  performance-
oriented companies that really
do sell and
try it out to see how you can get
in touch with the consumer this
is a super exciting topic and
using it is not rocket science it is not something
where you really need a lot of time a
lot of money but that is  already
with a few clicks on a web pictures
possible to create lenses and
to build experience is as an advertiser
okay who does it well but a few
examples i have two nice examples
i think the federal armed forces am really great
recruiting campaign on we put on snap
you  maybe you know that when
you drive through the cities you see
the Bundeswehr posters on the city lights
and the Bundeswehr thinks
totally holistically and it is a very
important part of the campaign and
it is a link between
offline and online through the network, i.e. on the
subway  stations and angus city lights
are the posters from the german army and
you can  attract a page with a slapshot where you can try out the different jobs that exist in the armed forces
, so
there is more to it than just being a soldier in the
armed forces, you can be a cook, you can be a doctor, you can be a nurse, and
you can take a look at all these jobs there in a playful way
and actually what i
think is coolest is that the federal armed forces
know where to pick up the right user at the
right time, because these are
young people who take the bus
to school and use their mobile phones to read
this snap code at the subway station
attracting and that is just
incredibly smart done
the
federal armed forces and that the other
example is zalando, for example
, we work very closely with them, they
clearly sell on lenses
where you can try out cool north face
products
and
then really with one click the  you
can buy from zalando via zalando the north face yes but they are also small
brands  on our pages and use
keen is a great example of
why shopping is such a big topic for you right now
, how what makes these criteria
special, so shopping is of course
something that our users and and and the
Germans are currently learning about the
pandemic  have that you
can do it online and i don't know
about you but i do
n't feel like going to the store at the moment, especially in
winter changing in the cramped changing
room and trying out things
and i think online the experience
can be significantly improved and
we want to improve the user experience in the online area
and think about it
if you can simply project different sizes
onto your body virtually with a 2 2
it makes things
much more pleasant of course it
also means that, for example, returns are significantly
reduced when I go to the
store  then i usually say that
i will take two or three things with me at
home a  I tried on and sent back more than 50 percent of
the things I took with me
and these are
all huge advantages that you can
reduce returns
you can try on products without actually having to try them on
in the cramped changing room
and you can
also shop in  building up the shop experience
online shops are all generic if
you remove the logo you won’t
see any major differences and
you have the option of really building up the
shopping experience again
and suffering a user in a
shop that he can
really try out product information
and has a shopping
experience and can experience a brand and there are all
augmented reality shops so how
intensively the topic is going to be dealt
with is how I would interpret it to me can
also be seen from the fact that you recently took over
a German company
analytics are what they do  yes
i think it was the same that you made this
adjustment  ability of clothes on the
body
because relatively large animals is a condition of
the scene so
you can read about a lot of money that went into it I
think a nine-digit sum was paid to you at one
point I wasn’t involved
but I know the guys from fit
analytics quite well we work  close
together and are a totally exciting start
up so there are 180 people to draw from
and
they have all
sizes from big fashion labels and a pullover from one
brand is just not the same cut
as from another brand and these
recommendations will definitely be made in the future
also available via augmented reality
that's my one
suggestion is made what size you
need from a certain product that
's right again so okay the topic of
shopping and fitting and
trying out clothes if relatively large just
really huge topic shop and that
just fits together we have  now apart
from a what becomes differenti, so to speak
ert snap right now when you are
looking at this cohort this at
this generation maybe there is also an
instagram topic there is certainly
also the stop topic but it is
somehow always there and also
always big
we are around here  to stay and
we developed a cool format back then with backing up stories
that has become the
standard today in innovations that
caught on and today stories are
something that can be found on all
platforms and we have
set a trend with this fm real backing up
this ephemeral that is gone after 24 hours
or after watching a
story and that is what makes things so
exciting for generation z who
know exactly what they are doing out there on the net
they don't necessarily want it to
stay on the net forever  but
that after that it's
gone, like a normal conversation, and
i think we have an incredibly
exciting trend there  ört there we are on
an exciting trend and
have developed a cool product and
today it is indispensable in the shopping area in the
communication area
that means somehow you
say emotional ranges in Germany as well as
about
equal to the island and I but
we have 13 million users in
Germany
we  the generation on our has the
generation z on our platform these
are 13 to 25 year olds but you
shouldn’t make the mistake of thinking
that the target group is very young 80
percent of our users are over
18 and therefore absolutely relevant they are
growing with us and  are of course also
exciting and relevant for the advertising industry
and what does he do prosieben
i saw there was at least
christian thiel we have a great
partnership with prosieben we
entered into prosieben has fantastic
content incredibly cool show
and we ultimately offer prosieben
and a second home namely  there  where the
users are the generation z are not
necessarily the ones who sit in front of the tv
and enjoy this campfire moment,
but they watch in a different way the sees
vertically the content and all
shows that are produced at
prosieben so whether that is the us singer
voice joko klaas  there will now also be on
snap and that is an extension of
this content on our site,
namely where the users are
in a different form in short form in
vertical form and a super exciting
partnership and we look forward
to having proSieben on our site
is then general  so that it lasts per
seven i can most likely
imagine but that's also brands have
understood how they have to work for you
so with the
federal armed forces strength so know
described on land too but
that's the way i have the feeling with many brands especially
when they are like that
reaching out to younger target groups that's sometimes a
bit i think that's the word for young people
clinch means being ashamed of others
like not so cool you try
to ingratiate yourself with the young people
somehow
but you have to have a very
authentic language for the
respective platform and also leave this cup
well, you can do that  do
n't use the same comb i'm 48
and the word grange is in fact o'clock
it just said it's yes that's how you are
authentic and i think as a brand
you have to take the users
seriously and you have to understand what's
going on in people's heads  the users around and
and if you look at the generation like
this, today they go on demonstrations they go out into the streets
for black riders
or free dsv future
i didn't do that when i was young
and it's totally exciting
the target group and the  the
generation is very critical and you have to
deal with the target group
and you
can't sell them something that is
n't branded  core is also part of it
and try it out it's important to be
authentic understand the target group we're
happy to help we have creative teams
at snap in germany and we
know what works but
advertisers just
have to have a bit of humility to
try something out and then develop it
I quickly believe that on my
own as well, but you are now
obviously open for business in
Germany, where you can contact me,
what does it mean, how big is
your team, Germany, we have a
larger team here, around 30 people, we
are growing, we are strong
We are well positioned in the creative area
and we look forward to
every advertiser who
wants to work with us.
We are well positioned, especially in the shopping area.
We have great products, great
development and,
in my
opinion, snap is an absolute must for e-commerce customers in the future
mostly for the customer directly or
through agencies wi  e we work extremely
closely with agencies but are
open to every customer and no matter whether large or
small, whether performance or branding
oriented we work closely with all
customers and agencies together ok church
so that as far as the update to snap I
think could be in the next few weeks months
we still have a lot coming up we have joint plans we won't
reveal everything but there's still a lot to come
would like to hear more again there's
now a bigger cinema, so to speak, that
we're doing on youtube with the carolina
there are a lot of the things
you're seeing right now  you described
didn't come up with a very funny video
so please tune in and
otherwise
hear and see each other as I said in
the next few weeks months hopefully
I'll be here again and at the o m
you're honored that that's of
course that's absolutely absolutely  absolutely
all right thank you fiancé
for all those who have personally
made up their minds
I would have something to do further training in 2022
, we finally have an area that we finally
have mr education and, among other things,
there are so-called deep dive courses
and we deepen very much in depth on certain topics that really help
you advance, e.g.
in the area of seo in the area of insta
marketing in the field of digital analytix in the
field of e-mail marketing there you can
learn a lot within a few
hours a lot of added value for
yourself and you also for your employer
who wants to do it intensively practical
either live and of course also digitally
and a personal
certificate of participation  at the end he can take a
look at what you are offering and abyss
com is currently available with the
voucher code there may be 22 10 percent
on all courses so again acquisition point
comes maybe stayed may
visit
[music]
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at mr